diese ergebnisse von heute abend diese
gemischten gefühle über freude und auch
enttäuschung sie sind für uns
herausforderung und ansporn zugleich die
vor uns liegenden aufgaben auch in
deutschland auch in der bundespolitik
mit voller entschlossenheit anzugehen es
gibt viele menschen die in brandenburg
und auch in sachsen ganz klar die
demokratischen parteien gewählt haben um
ein zeichen gegen die afg zu setzen
wir haben aber auch viele menschen die
ganz klar fdp gewählt haben um vor allem
auch protest auszudrücken
ich bin nicht nur zufrieden ich bin
hochzufrieden man sieht er wäre hier der
wahlsieger ist wir haben uns für
zweieinhalb fach gegenüber dem
landtagswahlergebnis 14 in sachsen
wir haben uns mehr als verdoppelt wie es
aussieht in brandenburg ich glaube viel
besser kann es nicht laufen wir hatten
zwischendurch das stimmt natürlich eine
bessere umfragen auf dem wahlkampf in
den wahlkampf lauf und denke ich das ist
offensichtlich dass sowohl in
brandenburg zur spd wie in sachsen zur
cdu auch grüne wähler hingegangen sind
um zu verhindern dass die hft stärkste
kraft wird die linken standen immer für
einen protest der voller achtung
gegenüber den menschen und gegenüber der
demokratie war und sehen ob ich haben
sich schon einige jetzt dafür
entschieden auf eine andere protest
fortzusetzen das ist absurd der protest
für den dfb steht ist ein protest voller
verachtung gegenüber menschen leben und
voller verachtung gegenüber der
demokratie wir sind nicht bis in die
parlamente gekommen der anlauf zurück in
die parlamente in potsdam und dresden
ist ganz offensichtlich länger ich war
optimistisch auch durch die gut
besuchten veranstaltungen die gute
stimmung im land aber die zahlen heute
zeigen sehr viele werden aus taktischen
gründen trotzdem partie für die fdp
anders gewählt haben